all right here we go this is the Reuben
report I'm still Dave Rubin and I have a
feeling that YouTube may not be thrilled
with this episode so even more reason to
subscribe and click that bell so that
you actually get notified when the clips
come out and joining me today is the VP
of the Trump Organization and the author
of the new book triggered Donald Trump
jr. welcome to the Rubin report good to
be with you buddy all right here we go
man I'm 50/50 on whether this stream is
going to be up by the time I finish this
very sentence right now sort of a win
either way right if they censor you we
can blow it up and make it go everywhere
and then other people will watch but
it's the same that we even have to have
that conversation right it's sort of
ridiculous we're gonna get to that and
that actually has a lot to do with what
you write about in the book here about
all the tech censorship and all that
stuff but before we do any of that I
don't know if you remember but a couple
days you were on the view that you
program and I don't remember that no
one's mentioned that to me since yeah do
you remember that so there were so many
things that happened in that interview
that I was like holy cow this is
everything that I talked about all at
once so let's just try to hit a couple
things in a row here so first off the
way the interview started where Whoopi
who I used to really like Whoopi I think
she used to be a decent liberal and now
she's kind of gone off the the
progressive deep end she couldn't even
say your name in the intro she literally
refused to say your name what what does
that feel like when you sit down and you
know you're in enemy territory and then
the way they treat you before anything
has happened well is it obviously shows
just how disingenuous the whole thing is
first and foremost right I mean they
invite you on to talk about your book
did you hear a question in three
segments okay I'm not a baby right like
I get like I'm gonna get hit I get that
in that case you know there's not even a
conservative on my side you know like
there's not a lot personality there for
that kind of stuff so you know I get it
I get that I'm going in the lion's den
but like come on they're gonna lecture
me about civility but you have me on for
a pretense the book you don't ask me a
single question about the book and you
refuse to
even mention my last name and I was like
you know this is going wrong real fast
but right she basically said the son of
the president then she kind of choked
out djt John Jr I think or Donald Jr she
said like she wouldn't say she never
said Trump yeah you know I'm like that
it's okay I guess people know but like
what's the per what does it serve yeah
but it does set a certain tone and that
that's been consistent I mean Rand Paul
was on there a couple weeks ago and the
way they were treating him but then a
few things happened in a row that I
thought were pretty interesting so you
started getting hit and you apparently
had done a little research cuz you turn
the question around and said to joy you
know joy you've been in blackface and
now joy has been in blackface she has
admitted it on the view she immediately
said she hasn't Whoopi then said well
I'm a black woman and I know what
blackface is it would be and you
supported Roman Polanski and when I told
a rapist it so it's not rape rape that's
what she said
you know yeah you're right sodomy of a
13 14 year old girl under quaaludes
you're right that's not rape opiate-like
if that's not rape I don't know what it
is and now you're seeing by the way like
literally the day after like it broke
like some other woman accused him both
ways that one rape rape like I just want
to make sure we're clear but what do you
make of the idea that they never get
these things turned on them that that's
what was so shocking nobody does it even
though we all know it correct it was
funny because I see that I mean in the
last couple days just doing these book
signings like even these guys you know
will come to the books on the other day
I love what you did on the viewing what
were you don't want to the view they're
like a ball it was not a funny to
rhetoric but you know I think what it is
honestly Dave so many people are used to
going on those shows they have big
viewership they have big following they
want to get invited back you know
they're there to pitch something and as
well as I I mean I didn't just go on
there for fun right uh
you know they're there to pitch
something so they're they're so
desperate about wanting to be invited
back that even though it loses their
five thousands episode I don't think
anyone's ever pushed back on them yeah
you know they can sort of say it's it's
leave you not views right there's one
view and if you don't have it you know
they're gonna go in after you and so I
guess I just sort of took their script
on them and people like how much did you
prep for a second
prep for that I literally I was like I
was like you know what let me have
something in my back pocket if we can
have a civil discourse
if we can talk about it I mean again
understanding it was not your intention
to flip it on that's why they sort of
held off but it was like they went at me
so hard I figured you hey if I'm on for
three segments okay hey we'll talk a
little bit and then they'll get rough
but like you know just the opening salvo
is just aggressive even the conservative
sort of come at you so I was like okay
like game on like I can play I mean so I
didn't prep but I went on Google for but
I was like stupidest things ever said on
the view like wow this was not like a
well researched you know counter-attack
not like it's like it was good to have
something in my back pocket that shows a
lot of that hypocrisy what does that
tell you more broadly about the media
though that they usually know they can
sort of say whatever they want and I
don't mean just the views but basically
sort of all all the lefty media can say
whatever they want you guys just sort of
take the hits usually and then the media
then will cover their tracks after that
that's what the game won't even go
because most people are afraid of the
confrontation on a live screen and stuff
like that there well you know their
concern like me the difference between
me and so many of you like I don't care
you know what the media says I mean some
of the guys that I you don't spend a lot
of time with now in politics and stuff I
mean they've literally had the reporters
call back like what is it with Dungey
just doesn't seem to mind when we I'm
like I don't like it means absolutely
nothing we really think that Kyle do you
think that's directly from your dad I
guess it's just listen I've been used to
it I think there's a genetic component
you know I sort of joke in the book I
say you know it took us probably 41
years to realize that we were much more
like each other than you would have
thought you know with my hobbies the
outdoors through this like my you know
sleeping on couches in the Midwest like
that's not his thing he doesn't
understand that and so I think if anyone
would have asked us prior to sort of the
viciousness of politics they would have
been like you know Don's the one they're
probably least likely and it was like
now it was like oh well they kind of
fight the same way you backed us in a
corner you attack us for three years
mercilessly we fight and you know I
guess that's the difference it just
doesn't bother me that much so I don't I
don't really care what other people
think of me it's never been something
that's fazed me that much and so I'll
get my part out and whatever they say
they say I don't freak out if I get a
bad press I get bad press every day like
they
you know anything I do and say can be
used against me I had I mean this is
relevant cuz it's literally today
Veterans Day in the book I wrote there's
a chapter about sort of the victory and
I say you know after two years of sort
of that just fighting during the
campaign you know when we won on
election night like I was not at all
like excited about it wasn't like you
know we won a hockey game and it's like
yes hours of and it was so vicious so
the the ups and downs the ebbs and flows
they're so intense it wears you down and
beats you down so when we won and
they're like we got it we I'm pacing
around like a caged animal be like no no
they're good they're gonna do something
they're gonna take what Hillary said
Trump supporters were gonna do they're
gonna do exactly that I turned out I was
right right meaning they were gonna try
to get that they were gonna you know
protest in the streets they were that's
what she's saying Trump supporters are
gonna do right they're not going to
accept the result 100 percent so I was
there like no no no like I figured this
game out now they're gonna do something
so so when John Podesta got on stage and
was like well I was like I was happier
about that even though it meant we were
still fighting and it wasn't over and
then I was that we had won which is a
pretty warped reality right again what
were you guys tonight
what was that night like though when cuz
Hillary didn't concede that night what
she did yeah it was sort of a wishy
washy concession and then it was like
let's see if we can pull some recounts
turns out we actually got more votes in
the recounts but you know so I wasn't at
all psyched it didn't hit me at you know
what we had won and accomplished so I
write a chapter in the book saying when
it hit me was literally like two and a
half months later and it was rolling
into Arlington and you know for the
wreath laying ceremony and I was like
I'm not an overly emotional kind of guy
like I said I can kind of
compartmentalize the hate and just move
on
but like dude it hit me pretty hard in
it i we're rolling into arlington and
you see the gravity of the
responsibility that is you know what my
father has to do right now like and i
was so happy
then to the it all hit me then because
he's the guy in charge I know he's gonna
be such a good leader I know he's going
to get out of these endless wars and
you're seeing it and like some guy in
like left wing like try it takes like
some of it
he compared his sacrifices ty said they
made everything all the BS that we've
been going through a hundred percent
worth because he's the leader now that
we need and they tried to make it seem
as their like I was obviously saying
that my sacrifices as a business as a
person over a campaign was the same as
the death of Americans like I was like
honestly I can't even engage cuz I'll
try to build but like no reasonable
person outside of like left wing and
like Vanity Fair and these like loser
pubs that will try to take like anything
you say and dunk on you like no
reasonable human being of the thousands
that have reached out to me that love
the book not one has even thought men
what they're saying
I must have meant was what I meant I
don't think any reasonable person would
but that's what they will do and that's
the sickness that is really out there in
the media in a weird way though do you
guys kind of need that now like it's but
you know you mean like it's sort of
become this self-fulfilling prophecy
it's like the media is awful everyone
watching us knows that they keep
doubling down on lies and and and racist
and homophobic all that now like that
working with you before we ever got into
politics right okay so let's just do
that real quick I was gonna save it to
later but but about eight years ago you
did my Sirius XM show it was on the out
to gauge annal I didn't want to be on
the gay Channel but they're like you're
gay okay so I guess I did start
somewhere but but it was separate but
equal you know what I mean you have an
equal radio channel but it's the gay
Channel but anyway I I got in touch with
you you came on the show and at this
time again eight years ago you were for
gay marriage your dad was not this is
way before he was running for president
or anything and I asked you about that
and I'm not gonna you can repeat what
you said basically it's not I have
probably said something to the effect of
you know what happy people are
productive people it doesn't bother me
at all know what you don't know I'm the
same way frankly with the trans thing I
spend a chapter on that but where I draw
the line is when it's like okay well now
Dave you can be a woman now and go
compete against yeah women you know you
have that MMA fight or something we have
Fox it was a man MMA fighter a male okay
transition to female get something like
the first fight as a female like breaks
the orbital you know socket you know of
female opponents skull and like I mean
you're a great champion like come on man
stop it like they're breaking every
woman's world you know weightlifting
record every bike so I finally sort of
been like man I can be as
live-and-let-live as you want but like
there's there's a line that we got to
draw and I sort of feel like today if
you're woke here like by tomorrow you're
all right it's a never-ending you know
goalpost like I can't keep up I try to
see you like what there's I want to see
the other side wouldn't hear the opinion
at least and like make up my own mind
but like now it's like okay I can buy
into this it's like wow he bought in
this it's all over work I mean they did
it the example I use in the book is I
talk about you know Martina Navratilova
yeah great LGBT activist for 40 years
like before it was cool yeah right like
she came out one of the great female
athletes of all time we knew her growing
up you know she had a similar story to
my mother escaping Czechoslovakia and
all that stuff and I was like she said
basically what I was saying and the left
destroy door so she could have the LGBT
crowd that she was an activist for that
she was one of the original leaders of
yeah I think destroys her as though 40
years of being the greatest supporter in
the world for them meant nothing they
don't you know so you know she has to
walk it back she's owned she's disgraced
you know three weeks later she has to
obviously come out against Trump yeah
because that's the penance you pay to
get back into like the woke zone yeah
and I was like that's weird like she
never had anything to say before she
grew up with us obviously you know but
that's how insane it's gotten and so
again you know everyone's like oh you're
so I'm like I'm pretty live-and-let-live
man like but like we have to be able to
delineate and I say it on Twitter and
stuff and what's funny is if I put up
anything on Twitter the hate like flows
be I mean honestly before anyone could
even read the tweet and respond you're
just insane but even then I think I see
these guys man you're there saying it
like I can't I can't believe it like I'm
actually agreeing with Donald from
junior and something like they're taking
it so far yeah they're even losing
themselves yeah it's so interesting
because what you're basically saying is
that the progressives of tomorrow will
hate the progressives of today that's
exactly how it works correct I mean you
know I say you know and they like to
make fun of it but I think it's kind of
truly John F Kennedy the leader
that party for so long he'd be all right
today right according to their rules and
their standards you know and that's what
it is I mean we're not up against you
know the Democrat Party anymore
they've been taken over by the left and
so when I go all around to the Rust Belt
and I talk for these people I would say
like this is not your grandfather's
Democrat Party they're like because I
see the Oh done you know we're voting
for your dad but if you know my
grandfather knew I was voting for a
Republican you know he'd be rolling over
and it's great if I go what would your
grandfather I say about two days
democrat party platform innit they're
like yeah you go pretty quick like the
light bulb goes off and that's when they
get it like the the party you know that
was for working-class Americans that no
longer exists now they're there for the
you know the ultimate fringe I mean the
example I think I sort of you know you
know Elizabeth Warren the other day you
know you know black trans I don't even
know honestly I don't even know what all
the you know Latin whatever they're the
backbone of Sicily I go so I go they are
a one 1020 fourth of the back will hurt
you know Native American status yeah you
know it's I'm not saying they're not
part of it of course they are not how
about you know our military veterans you
know how about teachers how about you
know everyone that's part of productive
society like that's the back but the
backbone is everyone together not like
the most like how far can we take it in
there okay
that's America it's like everyone's
America that's the whole point of you
know this great experiment like and to
go into these identity politics while
we're catering to you know the point oh
oh oh oh oh two percent of the
population should know that's you this
that America that's it's ridiculous yeah
and it's a constant movement of
destruction because to lift somebody you
always have to take somebody else one
day I'm gonna have to do a podcast and
ask you because I'm in it you know as a
gay man what what are your thoughts as
it relates to sort of again you
outspoken I want Avista homosexual
people getting owned by the trans
movement and like it's not enough after
the years that you guys fall
to get the Equality that you have donnas
it so that people probably pretend
doesn't exist as I told you eight years
ago all I ever wanted was exact equality
under the law that's what we've got you
can call now we're equal you call me
whatever you want you know you mean like
you yeah that's what I mean anything to
me the the those again the the further
that you go they actually don't want
equality they want more than equality
you know everyone needs some sort of
form of reparations you know oftentimes
for you know at least as it relates to
that kid for problems that probably no
one had ever even heard of or even knew
existed so it wasn't like they were
oppressed like some communities actually
were for so long it's like I don't know
I didn't know what trans was until a few
years ago probably you rated so that's
the thing they were going to whatever
bathroom they wanted to and it was yeah
I know but no and your dad even said
what was it like two years ago your dad
said the thing about if a trans person
comes in to Trump Tower they'll use
whatever hey listen I'm a builder I
would love to build one Universal
bathroom okay let's take people if I
don't have to build dual bathrooms I can
actually make I wish everyone would
share a bathroom I think it'd be
wonderful
yeah all right so let's shift for just a
second and then I wanted we're gonna get
back to a lot of this stuff but the the
leaker yes now right now I know that
we're doing this on YouTube this is a
live stream if we name the leaker even
though the name is out there you're they
are most likely gonna shut this stream
they might shut this stream anyway just
because we're now talking about it but
the leaker it's been named in a zillion
things on a zillion outlets it was or
it's already been on television Facebook
has said they're taking down content
with the leakers name YouTube's been
taking down live streams they did a big
one last night that they took down so
I'm just gonna read you the the
statement on this and then we'll talk
about it the best way we kind of ran
here right so a YouTube spokesperson
said videos mentioning the potential
whistleblowers name would also be
removed the spokesperson said that the
company would use a combination of
machine learning and human review to
scrub the content I'm pretty sure we're
getting both of those right now the
removals the spokesperson added would
affect the titles and descriptions of
videos as well as the videos actual
content so look I don't want this video
to be taken down but they're obviously
watching it right now the name is out
there there's a picture of this person
on the White House lawn the day your dad
showed up at the way
election I was it's interesting I've
gotten to be a part of the outrage cycle
it's a very fast line yeah what we've
been on here for about ten minutes I'm
sure that the cycle of outrage has
changed and as adapted to something else
since we've been on but you know I was
born of the outrage cycle I guess last
week because I apparently outed the
whistleblower even though it was all
over the Internet I go like you know i
retweeted an article that literally had
his name in the title of the article
yeah it was on the Drudge Report you
know the view goes like the drug who
knows about the drugs before I go away I
don't know it's like the largest news
aggregator anywhere in the world
probably right I mean I was on the
Drudge Report four days prior to that it
was in Real Clear Politics so I put it
out there Donald Trump jr. outside like
I didn't like I still don't know his
last names like Moses just retweeting
the article I could care less but I
realized pretty quickly it wasn't so
much day that they were outraged that I
had outed him it's that now that if
there are the name is known people can
actually do some research right it's
that's what I wanted yeah he's a humble
public servant who's just trying to do
what's right for the guy now he's a CIA
guy who was Biden's guest at a state
dinner who was good friends with Brennan
apparently who was in the photograph as
you mentioned you know the day my father
is president-elect and going to the
White House crying like a little child
you know in that group picture where
everyone's so morose and they're all you
know wearing black and you know they're
in mourning because it's the end of
their world as we know it was Susan Rice
or whoever else was in the picture like
they're like yeah that guy he's gonna be
super objective he's just a homo you
know this didn't start his lawyer doing
tweets you know in January of 2017 right
after the inauguration the coup has
started impeachment is next you know
right along with the stuff that looks
awfully like really weird child stuff
yeah oh yeah there's nothing wrong with
these people
you know that's the point they weren't
upset that his name was out there
they're upset that it's another Muller
you know they get into so much in the
book you know it's it's the Muller
investigation you know when he's an
innocent public servant he's beyond
reproach he's just a nice guy when he's
a CI a gay guy with ties went to Biden
when he's in the photo crying you see
that this is just this is not an
objective unbiased person this is the
swamp at its finest this is the deep
state guy that wants to help out his
people and they will do whatever they
can to attack Trump because Trump is
going in and breaking up their cabal
their system that they've built up for
so long that they know and love that has
made all their friends really rich and
that's a problem for this so let me ask
you a question as a guy that punches
back that you think I'm basically sort
of half step in this year by not saying
his name I mean I'm tempted to say his
name no I'm not you know that matters
because anyone can go on right now and
just type it in and figure it out for
themselves so I'm rather can't you know
frankly keep with a platform but again
the whole point you don't need to ruin
my entire let's give them a little bit
more yeah but I mean it's it's so much a
part of the book which is here that
social media censorship is like they
have decided like the mainstream media
to be the marketing arm of the Democrat
Party how do you think they coordinate
it so like something like this where
it's so everything that you just said is
correct the picture is there like
obviously all the connections and and no
one wants anything bad to happen to this
guy but but the reason they don't return
hey Alyssa I wish they would have shown
the same you're endangering his life I'm
endangering the guy life of a CIA I wish
I would have seen one percent just one
percent I don't need it all over the
same amount of outrage when like right
you know my wife opened up an exploding
pout we a white powder envelope of
people that was a Warren volunteer all
it none of that stuff comes out like
that's at my house that we went kids
like that's doesn't deserve outrage but
this guy that's working in the deep
state he's a CIA guy he needs our
protections like give me a break like
come on I'm not advocating for violence
of anyone but at least at least balance
this thing out in terms of that and so
it's sort of you know that outrage cycle
just shows exactly what we're up against
do you think your dad always saw that
thing like that sort of protection
racket between the Democrats and the
media yeah it seems like he always kind
of knew how to play the media better
than him you know when he was in his
career and you know I talked about in
the book you know when we went down to
launch the campaign and it was I guess
you know June 16 2015 I mean the last
thing he said to us
before he walked over to go to the
elevator and we went down to go watch
was just look this now we find out who
our real friends are hmm and so he knows
he understands the real world he
understands how it works he understands
how full of crap most people really are
you don't I mean like everyone's looking
for an angle and honestly politics is no
different if anything it's probably
worse in that effect meaning you're
great and you're useful until you're not
and you know the thing that is missing
so much is loyalty and it's it's you you
see it and so he's always known and
we've always known that the media has
been left-leaning it's just now that
they've given up the pretense of even
objectivity I mean you know you see that
the Washington Post you know the day
after the the inauguration oh sorry 19
minutes after the inauguration 19
minutes yeah wrote the first article the
case for impeachment I mean 90 minutes
you know that's about the amount of time
that Obama took to get nominated for the
Nobel Peace Prize rightly that was 11
days I believe but like yeah that's the
difference right so when I certain when
people would have had the impeachment
that started last week I go it didn't
start last week it started on November 9
2016 okay the day they knew he had won
that's when this thing started and you
know again if you weren't a believer in
the deep state prior to his you know
election I get it you know if you aren't
now you're a freaking idiot
so people say deep state and then you
know sudden Twitter's gonna explode in
conspiracy theories you basically mean
sort of the layer that always exists
because that's kind of what right but
everybody she goes on the emulation you
know essentially manipulating you know
the people's choice I mean you know
Donald Trump was elected by the people
of the country this is the unelected you
know self-appointed leaders of this
country you know if they disagree with
the president who was elected to do you
know the things that he campaigned on
well we're just gonna do that because we
know better and it's in that class it's
that elite and honestly you know that's
always existed but I think you know now
that that class is not only just existed
but they've become nefarious you know
they are doing whatever they can to not
only just you know do their little thing
but subvert the acts
will of the people and that's where it
starts getting scary do you think your
dad was the only guy that could break
this cuz the you know there's a lot of
metaphors for this so there's a lot of
analogies you know some people say he
was the ice breaker that was gonna break
it something I would say always saying
that it was just the chess board he was
the guy that was just like you're all
playing this fake game we're gonna toss
it up see what happened it's probably a
combination of the both I mean I think
the reality is if you look at sort of
some of the major examples of his
presidency I mean you know take Kavanagh
right how long do you think like let's
say like a Jeb Bush character you know
under fire you know
unfounded ridiculous allegations about
gang rape magically appear you know it I
know you know yeah how long do you think
Jeb would have lasted when the media
took the sound bytes that they wanted
really this definitely happened the
harbor's and like we're never gonna
question second maybe two yeah like
that's where I'd set the over-under
before he folded it would have read 19
minutes it wouldn't have made it 19
minutes and so you know Donald Trump
just isn't gonna you know buy into the
nonsense he isn't just gonna cave to
that kind of pressure and that's exactly
what we need today because we need to
really reset you know this whole thing
and so he is the perfect vessel for this
and so that's why when people well you
know it's a pretty aggressive like
you've been under attack for three years
I mean I see a lot of moderate you know
Democrats but I get honestly like I'm a
Democrat but like I wish they just let
him do his job
I mean he's accomplished things that
prior probe on uh you know had he gotten
the job numbers where they are had he
done the things for the african-american
community like the prison reform
Opportunity Zones
they would have knighted him you know
Emperor for a life he's doing this
racist thing wrong I mean he's like the
worst races ever because he's failing
miserably yet I mean it if you're gonna
fail at something it's great to fail at
being racist but yeah but it's such
nonsense I see that cuz I see it from
the characters I mean you know Whoopi
Goldberg would used that example she
can't say his name well didn't stop her
from showing up at one of the finales of
The Apprentice and hanging out with us
at an after-party five six years ago
whenever that was
now she was there she didn't have a
problem with us then that was another
thing I could have brought up had you
know what I mean there's just so many
examples of this you didn't stop al
Sharpton from saying all these
complimentary things Reverend Jeff Jesse
Jackson for saying hey he gave us based
on a wall street building when we
weren't you know when we weren't any
I know you know I have pictures with
half of the resistance like at dinner
right so that's what your dad meant by
that we're gonna find out who our
friends are because we had connections
with everybody in that done so much and
you know that's the reality I mean you
know when Al Sharpton needed a place to
stay in New York because one of the
stories in the book like he literally
called me to set him up with a broker to
get help get him a place there wasn't
this hatred so I think he'll Jill go
over friend of me isn't like it it's all
an act you know they got to play their
role I get it you know what I mean
yeah you know it's all sort of an act I
mean we see each other at you know a
cigar club that I go to occasionally and
we'll sit there and joke around you know
I know he's not on my side politically
but like that we are somehow has been
you know oppressing them for day like
it's nonsense like we were we were you
know we had good relations he'd been up
with my father's often dozens of times
throughout his career as part of that
that if you were to look at your resume
like your lifestyle your that you're the
son of a billionaire you grew up in New
York you're sort of supposed to be a
Democrat in a hundred percent mean I
always say like I'm an unlikely
Republican right I grew up in New York
City I have a billionaire father I went
to an Ivy League school all these things
and you know the big part I talk about
that is sort of the lessons I've seen
throughout life I mean you know I
learned about sort of that socialist
movement especially as I see the
Democrat Party going really towards you
know welcoming you know sort of
socialism communist ideals it's no
longer a fringe element of the party
it's literally like hey the leading
people are like hey we're vacationing in
the Soviet Union this is wonderful if
only someone had been talking about this
for the last 30 no exactly well I mean
that was one of the big reasons to write
the book which is like you know I hate
watching these people that talk about
these the great ideals of you know
socialism I'm like who have never
actually lived under it and again I
reckon I got a caveat everything on the
son of a rich governor I get it but my
mother escaped communist Czechoslovakia
you know I had a grand grandfather a
grandmother you know that lived under
all of that nonsense and I had the good
fortune of them recognizing the
blessings that we have here in this
country and so you know they from a
young age I spoke Czech fluently and my
grandfather would go okay he's got to
see the other side you have it really
good here just to never take anything
for granted just to never have that so
he would take
over there starting up like the age of
five for four to six weeks every summer
Wow my friends over there I've waited in
those bread lines day if I can assure
you there's nothing less glamorous you
know then an empty supermarket you know
this wasn't like a helicopter generation
I may have been five or six like you're
going to the corner store and you know
waiting for for bread wow you know I've
done that you know I saw as a kid I'd be
like why is like my grandmother not in
my parents wedding picture it was like
my grandfather well they let him out of
the country to walk his daughter down
the aisle but he they wouldn't let the
wife for fear that they would defect
like we're on a system doesn't let
people leave because they know they
ain't coming back
you know I've experienced these things
and you know to see them push this
mainstream thought now it's really scary
like I remember that my first memory of
fear that I talked about in the book was
going over there the first time I was
wearing like it was pretty cool because
the eighties I was wearing like a blue
jean jacket with like the stars and
stripes on it again it's kind of a tease
like yeah rocky for like holed out of
the line by you know a customs guy in a
military thing with an a chaotic Westin
Emile Ike was I there to like preach you
know the evil the great aspects of
capitalism I'm like dude I'm five years
old and not like one of like today's
five year-olds who are much more woke
you know they're asking about their
proliferation you see this all the time
my two and a half year old ask me about
the you know the dangers of nuclear
proliferation on the Korean Peninsula
and its effect on your macroeconomic
form now I think it always happens to
those blue you check the blue checkmark
kids who are you they're really woke and
I'm like it's amazing how it just fits
into the byline of today none of your
kids have asked you about string theory
and how no they haven't they haven't
bizarre hard to believe I you know I
guess they're just not that smart
yeah it's a shame I was really hoping
that they would be you know you gotta
get more elite school that's the problem
I know it's a shame so I've seen that
stuff I've lived I have my 93 year old
grandmother is still alive and I would
say like I'll get the call from her in
tears know this is not your typical sort
of 93 year old grandmother I mean this
is someone who grew up in Czechoslovakia
spend two years like hiding in the
basement of her farmhouse from the Nazis
the you know the real fascist it's not
the nonsense that we see today that it's
okay they can be fascist and they can
beat the hell out of people who are
right-wing you know conservative people
that's that's not a problem there's a
tacit acceptance of that in today's
media but you've got forbid you put up a
meme about someone attacking the media I
mean that that's outrage that's front
page news Ryan no filter is gonna save a
billboard of someone choking Donald
Trump in Times Square that's no problem
but if you put a cartoon CNN like Tom
and Jerry think oh my god choke the dog
in that picture and there was gonna be
the fact that the New York Times
literally called the White House to
fact-check a meme just goes to show you
how to arrange they are but like you
don't have a dog medal cuz this wasn't
exactly the Medal of Honor but the fact
that they're faxing it shows you the
derangement the filter you know by which
other people are seeing their news but I
get that call from my grandmother
because they you know she's got CNN over
there they don't have a conservative
outlet or even a moderate outlet and I
mean she's in tears he said you you
can't you can't let that happen there it
always sounds so good on paper it's
always so great everything's free
everything's wonderful but it's not done
yet like I've lived I was like no no no
I remember I've been there but this is a
woman who's been through a lot who's
calling me in tears for fear of her
grandchildren her great-grandchildren
and the life that she knows they could
live in this country you know that her
daughter got to live that American dream
she's worried about that just going by
the wayside and I'm like no no no I get
it like I'm pushing back I promise you
it but you know that it can take a woman
like that who's been through it all who
seem it who's lived it and drive her to
tears goes to show you I say listen
you've watched the debate I mean you can
find a Democrat that will say anything I
mean there's some really loony [ __ ]
there you know that they'll run with
Biden wants to send men to women's
prisons if they want to do it seems
totally reasonable you know Elizabeth
Warren Singh think so you know a
fifty-two trillion dollar bill which is
90 percent of US governing it's like a
wonderful planet while eliminating
private insurance you know a OC thinks
that 93 trillion dollars for the green
new deal to prevent counts from farting
and eliminate air travel that that's
going to magically pay for itself and
it's also gonna fund people who are just
not willing to work even if they're able
to work and that they don't find a
problem with that distinction is you
know this is nothing that that part was
in the state except it was in
the plan right except that we've earned
the plan that they originally put it
right in the whole thing's in mistake
but you know minor details you know in
and that's what it is I mean it it's
absolutely nuts so when I see that like
we got to combat this stuff all right so
let's talk a little bit about the way
your dad has sort of evolved over the
years because your PIN tweet is him on
Oprah what is that 1980 it's literally
talking I mean here's the most
consistent politician in probably
American history so it's it's pretty
incredible so he's talking about our bad
trade deals now this is 33 roughly 33
years I was talking about our bad trade
deals but what struck me about it isn't
just that the things he was talking
about then are the things that are still
irrelevant now but there's clearly a
change in his demeanor
now right he's much more gruff now he's
or and what what do you think that's
just 33 years of trying to get through
the system and now and that he kind of
like cos he comes off as very soft at ya
know it's hard for people to understand
I think it's a combination of it's
probably not trying to get through the
system it's more like you know talking
about it a lot hoping someone's gonna do
something hoping someone else will do
something hope you know you could throw
sidelines for so long but what's great
about Trump is like hey he's a man he's
gonna step up and get in the game he's
like I can't just talk to smack from the
sidelines I actually have to get in the
game now and that's what it was I mean
you saw it in 86 and he was right then
and he's right now he's sick of
politicians that you and I wouldn't let
negotiate a car lease you know got no
but the reality is this half of our
political you know they're making
trillion dollar decisions did you know
in some cases 93 trillion dollar
decisions or trying to that our kids are
gonna be beholden to our grandkids are
gonna be beholden to these are people
who've done nothing in their lives other
than they've never signed the front of a
paycheck they've never had someone's
livelihood their family's well-being
dependent on their success I'm running
another panel here in my house then 90%
of the politicians out there that you
know and so you know you have John Kerry
you're negotiating against Iran like
what does John Kerry negotiate it in his
own life
nothing do you think there's any risk in
having a more business sense to the
government or do you think that that's
like I think I think they're right I
think there's hey they just look at the
proof
I think there was incredible risk in not
having any of it for the last 50 years
look at what it's gotten us you know so
now you see it every day my father will
talk about these things like well
they're building the new Air Force one
so he calls Boeing and be like how are
you building a plant you know two planes
for this might take a billion dollars
off okay he's like he's like wait what
like well why didn't you well no one had
ever asked us before yeah we could we
can do that you know what we want to we
want to keep good with like no one had
even thought about trying to save money
you know he talks about it with some
other things that he's done with the
aircraft carriers and the systems it's
like well we upgraded the system it's
not really better it costs a lot more
it's harder to maintain and if something
goes wrong when we're in the middle of
the South China Sea we got to bring in
15 engineers from MIT to try to fix the
catapult you know so no one's even
thought to ask these questions if for
him it was a five-minute phone call to
save a billion dollars like that alone
is more than pretty much all of these
politicians have done in their entire
careers cuz no one's even bothered to
ask the question they just well here's
the price oh great that's the price like
why would we question that like well
isn't that the part of government like
you have to spend the money one year
because otherwise their budget it's like
but that's why the death as it keeps
going up it keeps going up because
everyone wants more power more powers in
having more money more planners in
having a higher budget and so you you
you fix things that don't need fixing
you create problems that don't exist to
justify an existence that is asinine
it's why government keeps growing at the
level that it is and it's centralized
around DC usually far away from the
things that they're supposed to be
managing and running with people that
have no idea what's actually going on so
you know I think you know Trump is the
result of Americans being fed up and
actually seeing that I mean you know
Americans despite the media's portrayal
of them decided they get it like you
know there's so much more on to this
system than anyone and it's why you have
Trump you know they're sick of just
being looked over forgotten I mean
America's number one export as far as
I'm concerned for the last 50 years has
been the American dream mm-hmm we have
sent that dream to countries that hate
our guts they hate our values they hate
our freedoms they hate everything about
us that's been our big export because of
stupid
practices by guys that have no idea what
they're doing up against people that are
literally experts in their fields you
know it had just got PhDs and this stuff
in there laughs in their ass off for
years that America is just giving it up
but we're giving up you know 200 years
of hegemony that we've had to appease
like people I hate our guts and you know
Trump's know the count or response to
that it's why you see China's Freimuth
oh yeah we really we really want to
negotiate against Trump and the media oh
they really love negotiating guys maybe
they're just saying that because they
know you'll bite hook line and sinker
cuz in all fairness
who else has even questioned the
nonsense that they've been doing like
they hate Trump because Trump's finally
pushed back after decades of them
sucking us dry sucking our jobs out
sucking our money destroying our middle
class now someone's pushing back is that
the crazy part that we're so trained not
to think about how the system actually
works over time that then when someone
comes in and says things so like NATO
for example when your dad was like well
some of these countries are gonna have
to pay their fair share like oh this
training the president of NATO is
actually coming up like hey listen you
know this was no fan of Trump
well NATO has raised an extra what was
it like a hundred billion dollars it
because true if you say you're gonna
take you know 2% 3% 4% of your GDP and
put it towards defending yourself do it
do it it's been at Rockets I mean this
was a pact before Trump but no one
bothered to say hey guys come on you you
you you owe this money they just said
okay I mean watching German do you think
our leaders were actually doing nothing
they don't they don't care it's not
their money it's other people's money it
doesn't matter it's no different than
Air Force One why would we ask to
negotiate who cares you know what I'd
love to get on the board of Boeing later
on so we're not gonna question them
we're not gonna ask them to do better
maybe they'll give me a really lucrative
position when I'm out of government you
know I watched last year the outrage
that the media you know Germany's really
upset that Trump is telling them they
gotta pay or we're not gonna defend them
I mean they are literally upset that
Trump is saying pay up your fair share
there meanwhile complaining that we're
not going to defend them against
Russians while they're giving them
billions of dollars a year coming for
Russian oil
so you want us to defend you against
Russia while you're giving them more
money than God you know in a in a
pipeline you know natural gas deal with
yeah you could be taking that from us to
guys like the hypocrisy of the thing is
I see you Jeremy outraged about it's
nonsense so you know Trump's calling all
of these people he's calling all of
their Bluffs and no one has in decades
so with the calling of the bluffs so
that sort of brings us back to the
Ukraine situation because it seems to me
call me crazy not me if you think I'm
nuts here but it seems to me that if
Donald Trump jr. was getting about 85
grand a month to work for a company in a
foreign land who he didn't have any
expertise and doing what they do in a
language I didn't speak I know nothing
about I think you see where I'm going
with this I mean well that's the
hypocrisy in the media we're talking
about hunter Biden of course yeah yeah
the media loves to do this thing of Oh
Donald Trump jr. attacked hunter Biden I
go yeah look Donald Trump jr. he's so
not self-aware I was like no no I get it
I'm the son of a rich guy I've gotten a
big part where I said it on Hannity a
couple times then I I didn't you know
give the three minute disclaimer the
second time I was on so they're like oh
he doesn't get that he's also benefit I
got no no I've benefited from my
father's last name I share his name I
get that I'm not pretending that hasn't
happened but also aren't you proud of
that in my honor we have this fear of
success here long but David the
difference between me and Hunter Biden
is I did that through the business that
he built up as a capitalist if he wanted
to give me a billion dollars I could put
it on a floor light it on fire and
that's our prerogative I mean that's
sort of you know the difference is I
didn't do it through my daddy's
taxpayer-funded office right you
magically become an international
businessman when we won before he even
took the presidency we said we are not
going to do new foreign deals and we had
deals that your buildings were building
in them we can't just pull out we have a
contractual obligation we said we will
not I was a big part of my business
that's why I'm so involved in politics
because that's what I did I got I have a
lot more free time now so I was like
okay I'll get involved in this and fight
for what I believe in that's why I wrote
a book but they false equivalency of
being like well how are you different
than hundred Biden how am i different
like we stopped when I was an
international businessman for the last
15 years okay we stopped doing those
deals just so
they could have no you know impropriety
story hunter bite and magically becomes
an international businessman you know
gets on a board of an energy company he
knows nothing about energy had no track
record and is making eighty-three
thousand dollars a month in the Ukraine
where his father's in charge mediate no
no that's off-limits I wasn't off-limits
for two and a half years you know kids
are off limits Baron Trump's not off
limits they hit him you know Tiffani
Trump who's in law school did nothing
you know just a nice kid you know going
to school she's not off limits I wasn't
off limits when they spent
two-and-a-half years trying to throw me
in jail for treason for taking a twenty
minute
unsolicited meeting been you know Hunter
Biden's off limits for a shady board
seat in a corrupt company he's off
limits when he takes 1.5 billion from
the Chinese government not like a
Chinese investor from the Chinese
government after traveling there on Air
Force two with his father well what
would the media do if Donald Trump jr.
did that but they showed me they said
they didn't talk about it no they
obviously they didn't mention the
business they knew nothing about it when
they're playing golf together they you
know I just say do the other thing they
how about this let's go earlier in life
hunter Biden gets you know a great job
at MBA right out of school happens to be
the largest bank and the largest
employer in the state of Delaware where
Joe is the senator signing favorable tax
legislation
he's brilliant guy he's a brilliant guy
so he manages to rise through the ranks
there faster than anyone obviously
totally a coincidence he then gets a
board seat on Amtrak at 27 huge he's a
lover of trains he's a lover of trains
obviously Dave I mean that's what that's
why he got it nothing to do with Daddy
controlling the purse strings no no no
that's off limits I haven't talked much
about it because I honestly it's not
even worth it but it like you get
frustrated you know because they have to
attack my personal life everything about
it go you know what would happen if
Donald Trump jr. got thrown out of the
Navy Reserve in two weeks you know for
doing a little of the yayo
yeah you know you know testing positive
for cocaine you think they'd have a
probe you think they'd give me the past
people don't even hear about that you
know turning in a rental car with a
crack pipe and all of these things like
then the media would have a field day so
much so I almost should go do it
because if when they catch it that the
real death wish man the aneurysm that
they would have known
would be good for us because it would
solve the fake news media problem their
heads would explode with outrage that
there'd be none left and we could get
Mac back to a reasonable discourse so
they try to do this false equivalency of
what's the difference I go that's the
difference
like hunter Biden made millions of
dollars through his father's
taxpayer-funded office has all this
other shade in the past and he's totally
off limits but you had no problem with
half of Congress saying that I you know
literally committed treason a crime
punishable by death for taking a 20
minute unsolicited meeting but Hillary
Clinton can go out pay foreign agents to
go collect dirt take that dirt through
the DNC leaked it to the FBI the FBI
then leaks it back to the press the
press writes their outrage story which
the FBI then uses as the basis of an
investigation two of individuals on a
campaign for the President of the United
States which started the whole Muller
hoax I mean where's the outrage but not
even the outrage like where's the story
right Sarah Carter Sean Hannity great
Jared a couple of guys pointing up I'm
like where's like you'd think that this
would be big news I mean if you're a
journalist like this is kind of a big
deal I mean this is a legitimate coup
and they're just like nothing to see
here there's nothing going on here guys
we're just gonna pretend this never
happened because it it goes against what
they would like to happen it goes
against the DNC talkers it goes against
that media narrative and since they've
made that cognizant decision to be the
marketing wing of the DNC we should
actually look into them you know for you
know for campaign finance violations
because they're just literally
contributing millions and billions of
free marketing to the DNC covering for
their [ __ ] so who in the course of
all of this I hear you on all this who
the core smells do you and I guess by
extension your dad actually take counsel
from so I remember during the Michael
Cohen testimony yeah it was one of the
first moments when I was like this
Russia thing is complete nonsense
but the reason wasn't because of
anything he said it was cuz you were
live tweeting it and I was like if this
guy is guilty it meaning you you were
guilty of anything
oh yeah and our lawyers or everyone you
know would be locking you up and put
here yeah because you're live tweeting
it's so my lawyers it was funny like my
lawyers
numeron like it's like you can't do that
like anything you say I was like I don't
care I'm right like I don't care
this is [ __ ] and I'm gonna say it I
think so I mean I've literally had that
conversation that sit down with my
lawyers new or something you're in a go
you guys are making one critical mistake
if I sit down if I just sit in the
corner and curl up in a ball and die or
you know crying my thumb in the fetal
position that's what they want like you
think they're gonna go any lighter on me
they're not Adam Schiff was on TV every
day saying I committed treason he's seen
evidence to the entire could you see
evidence of treason and collusion and
all I think I still haven't seen it you
know I mean you think if he's seen it no
one else has like you think hey maybe
it's time to drop it right now like it
wasn't in the Muller report but so I'm
saying I'm just not gonna do it man I'm
not gonna just sit back I get where
you're going from a legal strategy I'm
not naive to that it's not that I'm not
saying it was the right thing to do I'm
just saying I'm not you know on that I
get ya where they're saying I go I just
don't care and honestly at the end of it
there we go you know what you were right
you need it to push back cuz you could
see it I mean when they're I'm in
closed-door testimony with the House
Intelligence Committee right and I come
back I'm out of this thing after nine
hours or so of testimony I get out at
seven o'clock at night and I look at
Twitter and CNN and 11:59 Donald Trump
jr. was saying this oh Jesus Christ I
mean Adam Schiff is taking bathroom
breaks and leaking this business see
closed or closed door was supposed to be
totally yeah like can I go back I said
I'm looking back seven hours in advance
every time we took a bathroom break CNN
is breaking this stuff I mean three of
their big bombshells had to do with me
now they were all wrong they were all
false you know one of them was the
WikiLeaks like some random dude like
literally DME or sent me an email like
have you seen this it was like whatever
like let's call it June 14th right now
they'll eat the stuff to CNN and I'm
looking at the dates they look yeah you
have commented it was June 4th I was
like holy [ __ ] like they deleted the one
in 14 right so the 14 you delete the one
it becomes four so the thing broke on
like June 10th or whatever it was right
so it looks like I had this information
from somewhere
there it's a Trump builder he don't need
like 25 bucks and somehow like spam to
our email so like actually like hit my
email so I got there I didn't respond I
did but it looked like that and they
ston the lead email like I had it six
days before rather than four days after
the rest of the freak in the world no
different than sort of you know meet
outing of a whistleblower after it's
been out there and they're not like for
four days I'm just like oh my god no
bombs Joe Donald Trump jr. had it I'm
like here's the tweets here's the emails
like we're the only ones being
transparent and like you ever get a call
not even a retraction on some of these
the other you know Michael Cohen was
there when Donald Trump said anything no
his lawyer pulled that one
he's Lily or pulled it back cuz they got
it wrong and they're the guys leaking it
like it's so asinine like you know and
then they questioned about now
there was no questioning about him then
literally perjuring himself I think was
later nine times like I don't live
through it I'm like nope didn't happen
check XYZ I mean you know Jim Jordan
some of those called it out they sent
that thing back to the DOJ like hey what
about this nothing we're not playing the
same game and that's the problem I mean
there are some Republicans that are
doing it there's some that are learning
from from because Trump has talked and
serves hey you know you could fight back
you don't just have to lose because they
want you to you don't just have to give
up because they're gonna write a bad
story about you like but you know what
the problem is that mentality is still
there's like okay well you know we're
just we're gonna leave this a guy like
they would never give us that same
benefit of the debt I say hey we can all
play t-ball or we can all play hardball
well we got to be playing the same game
and we're not do you ever fear that that
or does your dad ever fear that that
game so I agree with you on the premise
that like we had to break this thing so
that we want to start resetting the
system in a sensible way but the game of
sort of constant destruction one way or
another that's dangerous you know
ultimately it is by the way I'd love I'd
love to break that game but they're not
gonna do it you know I mean they have to
work with us a little bit on that I mean
the perfect example I mean the us MCA
the renegotiation of NAFTA everyone said
it couldn't be done it was the worst
trade deal in the history of trade deals
I think everyone will admit that my
father
against all odds renegotiated with
Mexico and Canada that's great that
would bring over a hundred thousand jobs
back to this country
you manufacture
jobs where we need it it's been sitting
on Nancy's desk for nine months this
will pass with flying colors by she
won't even bring it to the vote because
although it would be good for Americans
it would give Trump another win
okay he's already got the economic winds
he's already good but like it would give
him another win and we can't do that we
got it would pass Dave you could do this
bill in 30 seconds because there's
probably not a Democrat that would vote
against this thing okay it would pass
with flying colors but you know what by
giving Trump a win we it would be better
for them to keep more jobs out of the
country to do that so they can resist
but you need a little bit but how about
working how about working on an
infrastructure plan that would do the
same and it's well needed you know how
about all those that how come there was
no outrage that Trump you know was the
guy they got prison reform done like
where was a Baba you know I mean they
have no problem letting Joe Biden
running around like his primary campaign
thing is like government has failed you
I'm like like no [ __ ] Joe hey you know
I'm with you on this one but like if
I've been in the Senate for 30 years and
in big government for 50 legit not like
hyperbole for actually 50 years dude
maybe you're part of the problem like
and that is the game that is being
played right now it's a shame again
Trump is probably the only guy that can
do that but like you need a little bit
of give from the other side hey I think
if anyone knows him you know he's
actually you know a pragmatist like
he'll work I mean hey prison reform
ain't exactly a conservative like
talking point right you know what it is
that it was the right thing to do
it's not gonna win him voters in his
base him probably won't even get much
credit from the people who are gonna
benefit much from it because I mean the
communities where they live a lot of
their general sentiment is to Democrat
but it was the right thing to do so he
did it anyway I'd love to see some of
that sentiment from the other side that
doesn't exist they're certainly not
today and certainly not what's wrong I
hear you man I believe me I've been
trying to clean up what was my side I
can't honestly say anymore but you know
probably no one quite so tolerant as a
you know someone at they're preaching
tolerance so you mentioned sort of
what's happening with some
the minority communities before what do
you make of what's going on right now
with the black community because I do
sense that through Candace and through
kanye west now and what was it that your
dad did just this week it was at the
black Leadership Summit or there was
another one of these I've been running
around but he's doing I mean he's
bringing you know people to the White
House he's given them a platform he did
things that were unprecedented you know
for for a lot of the minority
communities I mean you have all-time low
all-time low african-american
unemployment all-time low Hispanic
unemployment like all-time low female
all-time high business startups
african-american give me any Hispanic
community FEMA it like if again if Obama
did this everyone we like give it a
credit like the problem is I do think
that people get it you know I do think
that people see it but man there they
are like even so many of the Trump oh
they're like well you know you know we
get it we see it but we can't say
anything about because we'll get
destroyed I mean getting the information
down to the people is hard because you
the DNC controls the churches they
control the community leaders they
control all of this thing you know
they've had a stranglehold on that so
even if it's happening getting the
information down to the voter it's hard
because it's going through so many
levels of nonsense and you know this
didn't happen and you got so much
outrage where they're still pushing that
but I do think you know that American
you know the American voter the regular
guy gave them so much more credit
whether that's a trump supporter whether
it's the minority community I give him
so much more credit I mean we saw it on
the example I love to use is you know
you know back in June we launched the
20/20 campaign in Orlando in Florida and
I was also my 47,000 people something
showed up for an arena that holds 25
they stood out in the rain for 2 days
thunderstorms well how many people are
gonna still be here after the storm I'm
a little worried not one person left
Dave it was awesome I got to introduce
the VP who introduced the president like
it was this big lives right after the
Muller hoax was exposed and was like you
know Robert molar testimonials right mr.
Muller I'm tweeting like have you
actually read the Muller report might
get in no clue what's going on I mean
they just used him because he was above
reproach he was a former decorated
marine and he was leader of the FBI so
Trump can attack you it's not my purview
yes like the genesis of it all you spent
40 million dollars in three years and
you have no idea what it is like you
realize like he was just a pawn right
yeah
you magically selected 19 like leftist
donors to be the objective arbiters of
this thing and think come on
but we're there anyway it was this
incredible rally it was so warm it was
just insane it was awesome and I get
back out in 20 minutes later I'm
watching TV did you see those people oh
they're they're out there in their
flip-flops that must be their formal
attire hahahahaha it was disgusting man
and you saw the level of disdain you
know the level of hatred that you know
the liberal elite and the media you know
largely one in the same for the most
part as for like just hard-working
people who you know they think it's
racist for those people you know to want
to live their American Dream they are
terrible people Dave for wanting their
tax dollars to be spent on them maybe
they're children again rather than you
know some country that hates your
freedom values your religion every
aspect about you like like what
civilization would never take care of it
their people first I'm all for helping
the world frankly no country does more
on a charity perspective than the United
States of America but like maybe we take
care of our own problems like it's not
you're not you know one of the East's
you know misogynistic dude terrorists a
racist whatever it is yeah for you know
maybe saying why do we take care of our
veterans
you know before some guy they can't
stand us why don't we take care of you
our education system when we're number
28 in the world behind a long list of
you know third-world countries that are
crushing us and we're spending 10x per
capita like you know while we fix those
problems first with our tech like you're
not a bad person for wanting that and
and when I saw that disdain it's just
like you know that's you know some of
the stuff that triggers me you know I
too am NOT above being triggered even if
I wrote the book about it like it's that
nonsense that you're just like how do
you get through that filter it's
ninety-three percent of the media about
Trump is negative despite unprecedented
success
like there's literally not an economic
metric where we are not better off today
than we were under Obama but you don't
hear about it you know the the Democrat
debates how do we take Trump's Twitter
away like why don't we address China
like they didn't literally didn't talk
about China Joe Biden says it's not a
problem now I believe him because it
sounds on the payroll for billions like
I get it but like the others don't
believe it's a problem either so we are
we out of our mind so with all that in
mind and talking about the filter
because you're talking about the way the
mainstream media operates and then the
filter we're doing this on youtube I
know you've talked a lot about we're
still on air censorship I don't know if
we're still on our I may have to say the
guys name at the end I've been debating
it this whole time because it seems like
if we don't say it in a way I'm not
gonna ask you to say it but it sort of
seems like if we don't then we see it's
doing the reverse I grab a in there
right like I hate I don't like to cave
to anything again you know if I was if
that was my demeanor I wouldn't but
there are times where you're like no I
get you you don't even want to go there
you don't want to give that person the
platform because you know what the media
will do and manipulate it you know so
you know I I use I talk a lot about tech
censorship in the book because you know
I was I've been calling it out I mean
we've had this guy do three years ago
not even on air just what do you do
about this you know I used the example I
use in the book although there's
numerous was you know I got taken down
off of a Instagram for a post I did that
was hate speech when I was just like I
was one of the first sort of blue
checkmark guys to be able to be like
guys like I get like that you're running
with this Jesse Smollett thing like and
if it happened you know fry these guys
oh yeah there's no [ __ ] place for
that anywhere in this country like that
not even a little bit yeah but like you
know when it's within 30 seconds it's on
every mainstream talk so oh my god this
obviously happened I go guys has anyone
like asked the question like do you
really think like a really rich actor in
Chicago on the coldest night of the year
is going out at 2:00 in the morning to
satisfy his craving for Subway I don't
know like yeah it seems a bit like do
you really think that to you know white
supremacist walk you around downtown
Chicago ahead don't forget manga hats
with a bucket of bleach and
you know a noose made of twine like you
think they're really roaming the streets
of down you think they live for more
than 15 to 20 seconds without getting
shot you really think they magically
thought that this guy would be going out
at that same time they just I mean they
really had a premonition here like I
said he wasn't like asked this question
of like it just sounds a little bit too
obvious like you know Jesse may be a
good actor but he ain't a good writer
yeah it sounds it's not a great actor
but not a great actor well by the way do
you really think that like these white
supremacists were watching Empire
brothers watching Empire I'm like I
don't know it doesn't seem like it
really caters to that audience like yeah
you really know who this guy is so I
asked the question I got taken down for
hate speech and this and that in the
other and you too I put it right back
I'll be like Oh what I like am I not
allowed to ask a question anymore and it
was interesting is I actually I checked
my DMS not the people I follow but like
you know I'll just scroll through and
see what people are saying and the
amount of people did that took time and
I've done this a couple times when I've
called them out or been you know deep
platform or I see you know I had 57
million impressions this week zero new
followers of like hey you know Instagram
what's going on here Twitter or like
what are you doing and it sucks because
it's like something almost right I feel
it but like you someone has to call them
out you know again I'm just wanna I'm
that guy that's willing to do it I hey I
get I'm the son of the president well
you know we run a multi-billion dollar
business like I got a lot to lose if I
if I get this wrong but like someone has
to have the balls to actually be like I
just want to ask the question like in
like the amount of people that did that
reached out to me I mean they're writing
paragraphs to my DM it's like okay I
realize like this is a one in a billion
chance that you're even going to see
this thing but their take paragraphs you
know here's a photo they're taking video
of their phones DMing it to be back
here's me trying to like your tweet and
I don't mean like some political outrage
to like tweet or an Instagram post
they're like here's the heart lights up
gone god here's the heart Kimberly my
girlfriend like she's like I've had to
follow you four times this week I'm like
you know it was like that bad last night
did you unfollow me I see thank you guys
did you unfollow me cuz you're your man
like it's like no time like it thank you
but if there
reaching out saying you know I've been
locked out of my account for 24 hours
for liking a post which was you know
your dad's post of him with his
grandchildren you know not even the
political stuff and you see it and it's
like one after the a thousands and
thousands so I'm saying alright so going
on the assumption that everyone watching
this but believes this right like the
Google leaker basically said that my
channel was one of the ones being
targeted so I here you go right so then
so then I think a lot of people
conservatives are saying then why
doesn't the government get involved I
make sure they have to I mean these
monopolies again what is the problem is
this the conservative side has always
done the remark you know it's free
marketing I know it's not because what
they don't talk about is that those same
platforms get so much protections from
the government you know in terms of
there's some of the hates basically get
an insurance policy from the government
that so once you're getting that in that
policy once you're getting those
benefits from the government you can no
longer say well I listen to you but no
you not you and so they're doing it and
the reality is I think until I started
getting vocal and calling some of these
guys now there are guys doing it I mean
you know Kevin McCarthy's calling it out
in the house Josh Holly's doing a good
job calling it out in the Senate but the
reality is honestly most conserves
didn't even realize that this is an
issue and as I travel the country and
talk to guys in the base it's probably
like a top three issue for them because
they're saying dude if they can do it I
mean I use the example ask if they can
do it's a Donald Trump jr. with millions
of follow it to the president the United
States I mean you saw the example he was
my sweet was like Donald Trump searching
my handle yeah in Instagram Donald J
Trump dude you're pretty specific two
million followers and I share the name
of the president him and I did not show
up in the first six pages just fake
account is it Don Trump qpx underscore
seven six or two with one follower in
two posts shows up in page one and grabs
money though he's funny he's pretty good
Ian's he's pretty good he's gonna be a
is gonna be the next general in the mean
wars
yeah and it shows you so so those guys
are finally starting to get it but it
wasn't even on their radar so like it's
my job and your job to be vocal about it
to call out that hypocrisy but are you
worried though that then when you see
these guys all the progressives go after
Zuckerberg that's saying I'm no great
fan of Zuckerberg but what but basically
what I watched in that hearing a couple
weeks ago was a OC and Presley in the
rest of them
we're basically saying we can't control
speech because they're against the First
Amendment so we're gonna force you to do
it what's in that the fear though that a
hundred percent but it's not just
Zuckerberg the problem is this the
pervasive mentality over in Silicon
Valley so he a may have twenty thousand
people that all agree with a OC
and they're the ones actually sitting
there probably he may not even know what
the hell's going on because you have an
army of people that all feel one way
that all believe you know free speech
for me but not for thee that oh well
more than happily you tweak the
algorithms like I don't even know how
much he knows but you you watch them I
mean hey like he's not exactly right
winning and they're canceling him for
not being crazy enough to satisfy their
goals so the reality is we got to be out
there we got to call them out and we got
ahold of the test we can't just say okay
well you know I don't want a mean tweet
from AOC like okay what is the fear that
then you give the power to the
government and now let's say your dad
loses and now congratulations you've
handed the power to Elizabeth Warren who
would be more than at well and that's a
that's why so many think I mean that's
why you know some of the gun control
argument like you see well if someone
believes red flag laws make sense
whether I agree with them or not it's
almost irrelevant you see within seconds
you know Dave Shapiro put up the you
know think what if someone came to my
door I do I mean a sarcastic thing about
I bring a gun you know an Eric swallow
it Congress yeah this is why we need it
he shouldn't be able to have like she's
like a pretty reasonable guy not exactly
an alright guide and though he's been
painted as a Nazi even though he's
different
Orthodox Jewish like yeah you know
you're gonna say that that guy shouldn't
be able to exercise his second like you
can't trust the left cuz you know
immediately they will weaponize these
things but there does need to be you
know a dialog there does need to be
checks and balances cuz you see that
censorship and you see hey Trump utilize
social more effectively than any human
being in history in 2016 and you know
what they're doing it's a dry run for
2020 but they're gonna minimize his
reach they're gonna you know minimize
who gets to see it
who gets to follow again if I have
people dozens of dissing done I'm
magically not following you but I am
following seven left-wing media sites
that I didn't ever try to follow that
I've never even looked at they're just
appearing in my feed not as sponsored
links but you know I'm looking to player
I never
follow them but now I am you can see
it's a dry run to prevent them and for
to prevent him to prevent the campaign
to prevent other conservatives to be
able to get their message to people we
need it Donald Trump played monkey in
the middle with the mediator I'm just
going right over your filter yeah you
know right over your heads and bring my
message right to the people and they're
like how can we limit that we may not be
able to eliminate it entirely but how
can we limit it so then how is this not
gonna happen I hear ya I'm gonna keep
being vocal about it I'm gonna keep
holding a congressman on both sides to
task you know if they're sitting on
their floating win not actually I'll
call them out on it right like I said
I'm not in this business right now in
the long run I don't care like I'm just
gonna call out I've done it to other
conservatives you've seen that like hey
like I see you on Hannity you're
complaining about XYZ but like I don't
actually see you doing anything about it
there's one thing sort of pandering to a
base yeah there's one thing sort of
talking to those people but like you
know talk is talk action is an action
and they're two very different things so
you sort of make it seem like there's
action here but you're not doing a [ __ ]
like I'll hold those guys to task even
if they're theoretically on our side all
right I got one more for you cuz I know
you got a busy day today we're already
over but first off I just want to
quickly say cuz I meant to say it at the
beginning that we did not discuss any of
this beforehand what we don't you know
you your guys did not ask me don't say
this or talk about really walked in you
were like let's roll like I just think
they don't put conditions on stuff like
this you know again there there are
people I definitely don't want to you
know give a platform to because you know
I know what the media will then do with
that so it's it's there's always a
catch-22 but no the reality is and now
I'm gonna prove nothing awful in about
one minute I mean are you gonna get are
you gonna run I mean like at some point
does this all lead to you in 2024 no
right now the real Isis my only focus
for the next year is getting my father
re-elected my only I may not you know
again unlike Hunter Biden I'm walking
away from are a lot of our business I we
did that naturally created an opening
for me I see what's going on I'm the
father of five young kids I see the
results I want them to grow up in an
America that we recognize okay a lot of
people have done it man I get that like
you know Trump 2020 Trump 2024 too but
you know in the book signings I mean I
heard that 2000 times yesterday
no no exaggeration and I honestly
there's no greater compliment
you know from those people who believe
that who like you know perhaps what I'm
doing or saying the reality says I have
no aspirations you know beyond 2020
right now that doesn't mean that doesn't
change I'm certainly not gonna rule it
out I do enjoy the game I do enjoy the
game uh you know but I like I don't know
that I'd like the day job right now you
know I got to know I want that aspect of
it too now you know it is fascinating it
is incredible to see like these people
and again you know I'm probably much
more comfortable and you've seen that
you know in the Midwest you know in in
like the Rust Belt then I am in like the
New York City rubber chicken dinner
cherry circuit vs like I don't do it
like competitive shooter like but like
it sounds crazy because again I know
where I'm from I know who I am I know
I'm like yadda yadda yadda when they try
to owe me for that but the reality is
like I have so many of those that's
where I choose to spend my time that's
where my real friends are so I hear that
a lot but you know my biggest thing is
making sure you get four more years cuz
I think you can you can really change
the course of this this craziness and
every day is yet and I mean I could
write literally the addendum to this
book today in the amount of time that is
since this went to print the amount of
[ __ ] that has happened on my I gotta
write like three books yeah you know so
I do like it I do enjoy I do love seeing
the difference it makes I really love
you in the hand motions right now that
was a little cleaner so I gotta be
careful with that I'll you know but uh
you know I do enjoy it but again my only
focus right now is 2020 whatever happens
after that you know I there's plenty of
time for that conversation I would never
rule it out but again like I like the
fight aspect of this game I don't know
that I'd like the day job you know we'll
see what happens but uh you know it has
been an awesome write it has been an
awesome journey was awesome to be able
to you know put it in long-form in the
book you know rather than just sort of
you know 280 characters or less or you
know the first half of that in 140
characters or less because you can sort
of get your thought out however that's
manipulated and the press will leave it
up to the readers to decide you know if
I'm truly as terrible as everyone says I
am but that never really mattered to me
as we've discussed good finish and I'm
pretty sure he just said he's running
it's
that's what they're one of the guys did
that after my convention speeches are
like oh my god daughters from juniors
got a run Wow and I was like yeah I'm
not gonna rule it out they go
he's running I'm like wait like because
that's that's cancel culture I mean if
it's 2016 I say you know yeah I'm not
gonna do it and in 15 years I changed my
mind
oh you're a liar yeah I mean you
basically committed perjury I mean
you're obviously you know all this
[ __ ] we've been hearing from Alaska
so I never want to rule it out because I
know it can and will come back to be
used against you in the court of public
opinion so I'm never gonna rule it out
but that that was also definitely not
the affirmative you know yes it's
obviously it's in the works but we'll
talk off the record just kidding a
college aid Trump jr. on Twitter thanks
man thanks man